j'ajoute encore une manifestation
concrète de ces accords économiques le
projet d'un complexe hôtelier de 1000
chambres à leningrad le protocole
d'accord vient d'être signé a annoncé un
contrat de 850 millions de francs
environ
mais il est temps maintenant d'écouter
l'entretien que viennent d'avoir
christine ockrent georges bortoli et
jean pierre elkabbach avec le président
gorbatchev qui se trouvait donc aux
côtés du président mitterrand
explications détaillées sur deux jours
d'entretiens messieurs les présidents
bonsoir merci de recevoir ensemble à
nouveau
antenne 2 et europe 1 pour un entretien
particulier qui va nous permettre
d'approfondir certains points que vous
avez l'un et l'autre évoqué au cours du
séjour de monsieur gorbatchev à paris
monsieur gorbatchev vous aviez vous avez
plusieurs fois insisté sur les dangers
et les risques de déstabilisation dans
votre partie du monde en novembre
dernier au kremlin vous nous disiez que
la pérestroïka est irréversible sept
mois plus tard
est ce que vous estimez que la situation
est encore plus difficile que vous ne le
pensez eh bien écoutez je pense
qu'aujourd'hui je suis encore plus
certain qu'il ya quelques mois à savoir
que la paire historique avait tout
inventé irréversible et cela est
confirmé par
dernière quand événement qui s'est passé
en urss à savoir sur la réunion du
congrès du peuple sommes les opinions du
peuple entier se sont exprimés à la
suite les élections qui se sont passés
dans une atmosphère unique que notre
pays n'a jamais connu le doute son
histoire évidemment on peut parler des
inconvénients des côtés positifs ou
négatifs de la campagne mais c'est à
lens en avant sur la voie de la
pérestroïka est sur la voie vers une vie
civile normale ni d'où il vient et c'est
vraiment la preuve évidente de
l'irréversibilité de la pérestroïka d'où
vient alors monsieur le président
gorbatchev
cette impression que l'on lit que l'on
entende une sorte de fragilité de votre
position quelle est la plus grande
menace pour la paix respectées pour vous
même peut-être aujourd'hui il ya ni
double retors les studios je ne pense
pas qu'on puisse parler de stabilité
s'agissant de la paire historique
article un peu plus loin je ne
s'agissant d'une politique qui a été
proposé par deux décès us jeune homme se
rencontrèrent la dernière campagne
depuis le dernier congrès
cette politique a reçu confirmation
éclatante
d'autre part le secrétaire général du
csa était élu président une par une
majorité écrasante
mais selon une procédure secrète ira
bulletins secrets dont on commence donc
c'est un progrès pour écouter oui oui
c'est un progrès oui
au fond vous est submergée par une vague
de critiques
rajoelina
qui peut être je confirme et j'en ai
fait que le peuple veut la pérestroïka
et souhaiterait que cette période soit
cas à part des résultats tangibles en
matière économique
c'est ainsi que je vois les choses je
crois monsieur votre choix que l'un des
grands problèmes
le grison casser la lenteur du
développement de votre économie ce qui
va me permettre de poser une question
peut-être à monsieur mitterrand est ce
que l'europe ce que la france doit
soutenir la pérestroïka en injectant des
crédits d investissement en urss
oui je crois que c'est un devoir pour
les pays démocratiques que de contribuer
dans la mesure de leurs moyens à la
réussite de la pérestroïka le mouvement
vers lequel se dirige vers historique a
été dix ans c'est un mieux pour tout le
monde et si l'union soviétique éprouvent
des difficultés il faudrait débattre
pour son propre développement
les pays d'europe et d'ailleurs qui
souhaitent la réussite doivent y
contribuer il prend que c'est ce que
fera la france je le répète dans la
mesure de nos moyens
il devient il ya le panier de la
ménagère il y a aussi les nationalités
vous adapter au mieux je sois ici mais
pas seulement bien ce que je dirai même
davantage l'essentiel est acquis
pour les résultats de l'américain
propose sur des épaules de notre
personne mais voilà périphériques à
notre place et nous qui en avant la
période pour sa vérité c'est nous qui
savons bien ce qu'il nous faut j pour
résoudre certains programmes toute façon
c'est d'autres pays y participent sur la
base de l'égalité
parmi ces problèmes monsieur gorbatchev
ya le problème des nationalités en union
soviétique il va y avoir un congrès des
nationalités
vers la fin du mois de juillet comment
trouver une approche commune à des
problèmes qui paraissent chaque fois si
spécifique et qui représentent pourtant
une même aspiration
je pense que vous connaissez mon dernier
discours n'est ce pas la première partie
de ce discours est une constatation de
l'inquiétude que nous éprouvons et toute
la société
il dit quant aux deux tiers restants de
ce discours c'est un programme
constructif il existe des possibilités
pour que ces problèmes soient résolus au
cours de la deuxième étape de la réforme
politique qui va porter précisément sur
les républiques sur les organes locaux
des pouvoirs locaux
nous avons des propositions solides qui
doit fermer bon d'en discuter et de
faire quelque chose ou voisins
l'alliance
mais concrètement je dirais ceci nous
estimons que notre situation est unique
titre en ce moment unique au monde
entier il réussit et malgré les côtés
négatifs qui se sont manifestés
notre union existe depuis plus de 70 ans
du miel mais malheureusement nous avons
cependant parcouru un chemin est très
long
nous avons développé les cultures des
économies nous avons à gérer d'égalité
n'oubliez pas qu'au moment des
révolutions nos peuples n'étaient pas au
même niveau de développement il est
actuellement du ikea sorte d' amalgame
de fusion au midi les points de vue de
l'économie de la culture m
au fond nos peuples se sont mélangés
aussi il n'existe pas une seule
république
et n'oubliez pas au moins une dizaine de
nationalités et c'est pourquoi nous
pensons et c'est important je le sais ni
nous ni que la voie vers la solution du
problème se trouve dans le développement
de l'union et le doublement les
républicains dont il faut renforcer la
souveraineté
il faut élargir leurs droits leur
autonomie a vu garantir les droits des
minorités nous développer la culture
dans une usine où une essner république
une bouffée en nous fondant sur la quina
au dieu de le détruire
pourquoi deuxième là pour aller de loi
monsieur le président dans le dialogue
par des moyens qui ne sont pas la
violence
we dance movie bien sûr cela base de la
démocratie
sur la base des amendements
constitutionnels qui vont se faire il a
fait un nom et processus démocratique
s'est dit aussi que les modifications
vrai il est naturel que les sens d'une
telle situation les éléments instables
se forge ou au grenier du temps nous
voudrions de garder et il est dans le
money g20 c'est super aistrika is you
dark pools comme s'ils atterrissent
troïka feront les avéré n'est pas qu'on
souffrirait tous les deux au cours de la
visite vous avez beaucoup dit que
l'après guerre avait vécu en tant que
président de la commission européenne
pour six mois
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
vous pouvez prolonger les rapports entre
l'europe de l'ouest indépendante forte
autonome avec l'union soviétique et que
le processus européen qui conduit à la
fin du siècle se développer cette
conversation va bientôt s'arrêter
je pense qu'il était intéressant pour
les français d'entendre surtout
l'opinion de notre
it et du président de l'union soviétique
grand peuple ensemble de grandes nations
qui représente une grande histoire
il est chez nous nous l'entendons et
nous le recevons avec beaucoup d'intérêt
bon mais les problèmes d'asile human qui
touche au développement de la
pérestroïka cela relève de la
souveraineté soviétique
on pourrait dire c'est leur affaire mais
c'est aussi la no c'est leur affaire
parce que tout ce qui se passe là-bas
intéresse le reste du monde
de même le problème réel des
nationalités dans cet immense pays avec
les degrés de développement différent
qu'on a signé les diamants
c'est leur problème ça nous intéresse
aussi car les répercussions de l'ordre
du désordre l'instabilité ou non en
union soviétique commande aussi
l'équilibré du reste du monde
mais il est un troisième point sur
lequel j'insiste c'est que le processus
de paix qui passe par le désarmement
intéresse la france tout autant que
l'union soviétique et de ce point de vue
je réponde à votre question l'existence
de la communauté européenne que je
préside présentement son renforcement
sa cohésion peut contribuer puissamment
au développement du processus de paix en
europe dans le monde nous présentons 320
millions d'habitants nous avons une
économie puissante ce nous sommes la
première puissance commerciale et nous
sommes les voisins directs de l'union
soviétique donc de ce fait j'affiche sur
ce point beaucoup de choses dépendent de
l'union soviétique chez elle et ses
dirigeants
c'est la chair de ce peuple beaucoup de
choses nous sont communes alors
justement monsieur vidant vous faisiez
états à propos de la chine de frais
occupation largement commune lors de la
conférence de presse de tout à l'heure
est ce qu'on peut imaginer vous avez
fait une déclaration commune l'un et
l'autre sur le liban ce qui est rare
dans notre pratique diplomatique
est ce que l'on aurait pu imaginer une
forme de déclaration commune sur les
événements en chine
on peut tout imaginer cela n'a pas été
fait en tant que déclaration est créé
été publié mais je crois que sur
beaucoup de points nous avons partagé
les mêmes sentiments
cela dit la politique de l'union
soviétique n'est pas la politique de la
france et versa ce que je dis de mes
regards et travis le mot regrette un
terme diplomatique
regarde ce qui est une sorte de
régression de graves reculs dans le
développement est en évolution de la
chine contemporaine se considère comme
une blessure pour l'équilibré mondial
est avant tout cela pour le peuple
chinois mais nous n'avons pas prétendu
mettre d'accord dans cette entrevue qui
a duré quelques heures sans doute mais
pas assez pour brasser tous les
problèmes du monde
une déclaration commune sur ce sujet
ajoute monsieur mitterrand vous receviez
l'hiver dernier monsieur walesa à bari
mais est ce que monsieur gorbatchev
recevrait à moscou monsieur walesa pour
montrer son approbation de cette
démocratisation accélérée qui a eu
actuellement en pologne
il y avait le store
je viens de répondre à cette question à
la conférence de presse bon non la
résumer je me la pète
c'est ici que nous avons d'excellentes
relations avec la pologne notre voisin
si nous avons des contacts intenses sur
tous les plans économique culturel
touristique et es9 es10 un peu gêné ces
contacts se multiplient jugé samedi
limite de nouvelles de nouveaux éléments
s'y ajoutent tous les jours de nouveaux
représentants des institutions
politiques apparaissent ni juste ni dans
le cadre des échanges entre morges
navigua aux associations pourquoi ne pas
organiser une telle visite
je n'y vois aucun inconvénient question
contraire si vous le préfet si vous le
permettez
la roumanie n'est pas un exemple de
démocratisation accélérée
demain que la france vous allez
justement à bucarest
est-ce que je ceausescu n'est pas un
petit peu un allié gênant encombrants et
intrigante n'établissait pas des fiches
d'identité volées pays va nous sommes en
quelque sorte
oui mais si nous des pays qui est des
naissances et autres pays et je ne
prends pas sûr voir le droit de vous
fondre jugé le peuple roumain par
exemple c'est le peuple roma qui doit
résoudre ses propres affaires
intérieures sur mathieu maumus ni la
roumanie moderne le mérite certainement
niveau match et vous avez parlé du
bicentenaire et vous avez vu la bastille
hier est ce que le mur de berlin n'est
pas une des dernières bastide
aujourd'hui est ce que les conditions
historiques ne seront pas bientôt
remplie pour qu'il disparaisse
vous pensez qu'on m'avait posé une
question à traiter ou non lieu d'achat
minimum c'est beaucoup de choses sont
nés en europe après la deuxième guerre
mondiale de la facile il ya eu la guerre
froide et une dose nord où il dit we
store la guerre froide est terminée
atteint guerre froide
maintenant tombe dans l'oubli à
kissimmee x tina et le mur aussi alors
que finisseur est tout neuf libyens je
pense que le meilleur n'est pas
d'obstacle peu plus rude avec un tram à
la construction en europe et asie ainsi
par exemple 2 million d'hommes armés qui
sont là armés jusqu'aux dents ça c'est
un obstacle à une écoute et ne vous
écartez pas les mêmes fondamentaux
mina qui entoure les journalistes les
méthodes sont certes nécessaires
le rouge et or mais tu ne passes pas mal
tournant maintenant de repenser vos
questions vous n'êtes pas offenser non
pas du tout si vous permettez nous avons
être obligés de cesser cette
conversation
vous avez beaucoup parlé qu'avez vous
avez en commun peut pas nous promener
même si c'est un intéressant à travers
toute la planète
ce que nous avons à faire c'est dommage
mais c'est comme ça c'est la loi du
genre
ce que nous avons offert en commun
d'abord c'est à bâtir une relation aux
cosmétiques solide politique
constructive ensuite c'est à défendre la
paix est donc à venir un désarmement
contrôle et simultanée des yeux bien
ouverts et c'est aussi à bâtir l'europe
notre continent comme ben voilà on a
beaucoup de choses à faire en sang on
n'a pas tout à fait ensemble
et puis les soviétiques ils ont à faire
ce qu'ils ont à faire ensemble et chez
eux pour les affaires qui les regarde je
pense que cela permettra de classer un
peu l'ordre de vos questions à nous
poser une question pour éviter le mig
soviétique qui s'est écrasé hier en
belgique après avoir traversé cette
future maison commune c'est de the rock
quel est votre interprétation monsieur
gorbatchev
m
eh bien je regrette cet incident les
belges de sa routine
les belges connaissent les causes de
l'accident et nous avons transmis nos
condoléances
évidemment ce genre d'accident peut
arriver nous somme yves mais il vaut
mieux les éviter
tout à fait je voudrais pousser ce titre
ici je profite de cette rencontre avec
le président de la france nancy pour
féliciter
il peut plus forcer à l'occasion du
grand des centenaires vivent idées de la
révolution français nous sommes très
heureux d'être ici
à cette occasion nous sommes heureux de
partager votre joie on a joué contre
nous et nous avons souligné notre
respect profond de moi la france et le
peuple de france
même si son équipe dans super mario
mercier